Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
uh,
November 12th.
I'm all Billy freckle face is off the road for the first time in a awhile.
First time in a while.
And I have to tell you,
I don't know what to do with myself.
It's phenomenal.
I wake up on my own bed,
you know,
although I do feel estranged from the lovely Nia,
we haven't seen much of each other.
I'm just kidding.
That word has never used.
It's always used when,
um,
a couple breaks up.
It's strange,
you know,
like you're never a strange from a family pet.
Right.
Do they ever say that on the news?
Mel Gibson and his,
his strange Dalmatian we're seeing,
trying to reconcile,
um,
you don't,
don't Ya,
you don't bill.
You could always just look words up and just figure out what they mean rather
than just trying to figure him out how people use them.
Do you really how many words there are in the English language that,
um,
I know how to use them,
but I could not give you a definition.
I just keep hearing people say him.
You know,
like when you listen to some dude from the fucking hood back in the day,
first time you heard that's dope.
And you're like,
that's dope.
He's a dope for that.
He's saying it's stupid.
I,
you know,
and then you just gradually fig.
Oh,
it means something good.
Why do they do that?
Why do they make it mean the exact opposite?
Why is this some sort of passive aggressive way to frustrate white people
because of all the bullshit we've done to them.
Oh Geez.
I don't know.
And you go back over to your white friends
with the words make sense to you,
you know?
Um,
anyways,
this is the Monday morning podcast with a fucked in my dog.
Go Cleo,
Cleo.
There you are.
Start.
You start looking at do you figured out how to open a door?
That would be a problem.
Now that I've called you and you think I'm going to give me attention,
beat it.
All right,
thanks for the kiss.
Okay.
Anyways,
this is the Monday morning podcast.
If I haven't said it 87 fucking times yet.
As promised last week,
I said,
you know what,
I'm going to do Ari Shaffir skeptic tank.
And you know what,
I'm a man of my word even though I still can't pronounce that skeptic tank.
Um,
I did it at the comedy store.
It was great.
We did it right out there on the patio and a,
there's a bunch of tour buses keep coming up.
So if we keep getting interrupted by the public and I've got to tell you,
like nine tour buses came up full of tourists.
Not One of them recognized me.
And I'm going to tell you it bruise my ego.
You know why?
Let's funny,
but I'm dead serious.
I was,
I wanted that moment.
Well,
Hey,
that's that guy from the thing.
I really like what you do.
I wanted that to happen.
Yeah.
I'm not ashamed of that.
Why the fuck you take?
I've got in this business.
Why do you think I get on the God damn stage and dance like a fucking monkey
every night?
Okay.
Cause I want to improve your day.
No,
it's all about me.
All about me and my credits.
Um,
anyways,
what a week Han people,
what a week of fucking stress.
My apologies to everybody out there in the red states.
I know you wanted a,
uh,
what the fuck is his name?
Mitt Romney.
His real name.
Willard Willard Mitt Romney.
Okay.
To get pilot Ford
from some white land you'll never heard of.
I'm a 26 Willa
raw.
Um,
you know what actually saw something with uh,
Lord of the rings.
Actually watched a little bit of that shit.
I watched it for I think about 20 seconds.
It was the white hair dude with the guy.
Looks like Ricky Schroder if Ricky Schroeder got fucked by Spock.
Okay.
Oh sorry.
I liked that one.
Um,
and I was standing there and the courses are some broad there who like you're
supposed to respect but for,
for no fucking reason at all.
She's showing way too much skin.
You know,
just everybody in like middle earth in like in the future.
And in the past they all have fucking bikinis on with like a sword or some sort
of knife.
When can that ever be in the presence?
That's what they should do.
That's what you bitch,
you should be doing when you go down to the beach with your little skimpy outfit
on,
you should have a nice fucking,
uh,
Daniel Boone knife
in there.
And then
all the fucking,
the,
I don't want to say players,
but I don't know what else to say that guys who know how to talk to fucking
women,
I'll leave you alone because they see the knife,
but there's a price.
There's always a price to pay.
You'll have a bunch of fucking nerds following you cause they'll think you're a
f.
Don't know why the word Willow's coming into my head is that one of those
references.
Okay.
You know,
I found out the other day that led Zeppelin was really into Lord of the rings.
I didn't realize that when they was singing about all that shit.
Cause in the doc is depth of mortar.
Is that from fucking a Lord of the rings?
You know,
I bet it's a wonderful book.
Okay.
You know,
it's just that you got to sit down and read all three of them.
Oh my God,
what's going to happen next?
Or they're going to,
I think,
going to get up to the surface or they're going to go down towards the,
the heated core of the earth,
middle earth.
And what is a fucking son down there that a nerd realize
even nerd should know that.
Right.
Anyway,
so I'm watching this shit for like 20 seconds.
I'm like,
I'm going to give it a shot here.
I'm going to try,
you know,
or at the very least get a couple more references for my podcast.
And I'm sitting there,
right?
And the old,
the Obi wan Kenobi looking guy talking to a Ricky Schroder who got fucked by
Spock and the lady with their fucking Bikinian or knife.
I didn't know if she had that.
I'm probably thinking of Princess Leia when she was next to that fat fucking
toad when Boba Fett got killed.
Right.
And,
um,
all of a sudden there's white horse comes in,
all white horse comes in and uh,
and the Ricky Schroder who got fucked by Spock is like,
I dunno what he said.
What is up with that if I don't know what he said and the fucking Obi wan Kenobi
guy goes,
oh,
that's so and so the Lord of all horses.
Huh?
It was,
how do you watch pass that line?
Is that really the Lord of all horses?
You fucking senile old coot the fuck is wrong with you.
And not to mention subtly racist.
Why is the Lord of all horses is widest fucking chuck?
Huh?
Coming up with good hair.
Main just flowing.
How come,
how come I couldn't bend my like one of those Arabian horses,
you know,
jet black with the sun shining off the side,
seeing all the muscles,
you know.
Hey,
you here to hear first?
I think that the fucking,
I think it's a little racist.
Okay.
Why isn't all white horse the Lord of all horses
isn't racist to do that?
Or are other horses and like ponies,
you know,
horses and ponies and never get along black horses.
We'd make it fun.
The point with the ponies isn't a motherfucker.
Oh Jesus.
Um,
anyways,
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about.
I just thought it was ridiculous.
The Lord of all horses and you're sitting there eat your popcorn and your
fucking racist pcs.
Just eating that shit up.
You know,
I saw a couple of,
I actually saw a couple and went out and I saw,
I saw that.
And um,
I liked it,
but it was funny when Ben Affleck,
they say,
what's your name?
And he goes,
my name is Tony Mendez.
I remember thinking in my head going,
Mendez,
I think that's a Latino name.
I know it's not a white name.
I know.
I've never met anybody.
I never met a white guy.
Hey,
what's your name?
Ah,
Larry.
What?
Rodriguez.
Larry Mendez.
It's not,
you know,
it's not like one of those crossover names.
So in the end of the movie,
spoiler alert,
they had,
this is just shit in the credits.
They just have a,
you know,
they have a picture of everybody,
each cast,
cause this was a true story.
So each cast member
is,
um,
you know,
I should talk to this,
I should talk to Neil about this.
You know what that's is,
this is it.
We're going to do a fucking,
uh,
another Nia log this week,
and I'm going to talk about this because they had,
you know,
the six actors who are fucking unreal,
who played the,
uh,
the people trying to get out of Iran.
They showed a closeup picture of the actor right next to a closeup picture of
like the photo id of the person that they were playing and it was fucking dead
on.
They looked exactly like the person and then there's like another minute or so
credits.
And then they finally showed the real Tony Mendez.
And the picture is like a full body shot of the guy from like halfway across the
room shaking hands with Jimmy Carter.
And you're looking at the guy and he looks like Bartolo Colognes,
dad and me.
And Nia just started laughing our asses off.
And you know,
it was,
it was one of those moments,
one of those Hollywood moments.
And then I looked on the internet and there was people complaining going,
what the fuck?
You know,
how come you couldn't get a Latin actor to do it?
But bup,
bup,
booed,
the,
the and all that shit.
You know?
And this is what I got to say about that.
I definitely think it's fucked up.
Why don't I just say what I had to set about to say about that?
Like,
like what?
I was just going to present all this shit and then move on.
All right.
I don't know how to say my points without having some sort of intro.
And now here is what I think about that.
I think it's fucked up cause it was a real dude and he's a hero.
He did some unreal shit.
So because it's a real dude who did some real heroic shit,
you should have a lat dude
play the guy.
So everybody knows that that win is in their column.
You know,
that's one full Latinos,
you know,
so the next time you get into a bar room argument,
well don't,
and fed of the airplane and then the Latin guy could be like,
yeah,
well we're the ones who got those six motherfuckers on the play and got them
into Canada.
Right.
And all of your shit.
Both sides.
You were in a bar,
so none of your red.
It's all based on the movies.
But now it's going to cause a fight in a bar because some of them,
it was a white guy.
The guy's to know who's fucking Tony men days and say fuck you and why was it
played by Ben Affleck?
And then there's going to be a big fight.
Yeah.
But on the other side is if you got a fucking million dollars and you,
you need the movie to sell,
what do you do?
I still think they should at,
they should have gone.
Well they should've got Luis Guzman.
Yeah.
Oh Jesus.
The wheeze.
Guzman is Tony Mendez.
I know.
Fucking nothing.
You know what?
That's one of the ones I've got to talk to me about that shit.
But it's,
it's a good movie.
You should definitely go see it.
But I've got to tell you,
that was inadvertently fucking hilarious.
Um,
like me and Nia walked out and started joking about it and by the time we got
out of the movie theater,
we were crying,
laughing,
and everybody
was looking at us like we were out of our minds.
We went to this one of those.
We want you to one of those fucking malls.
I hate going to,
you know,
those new malls that they make when they try to make it look like this little
city where there's no crime and everybody gets along.
You know,
I don't just mean like a mall.
We got,
you know,
the big anchor stores and then they put a fucking bunch of shit in the middle of
it.
I mean what it's like outside and they have like a trolley and a water fountain
and it plain like big band music,
you know,
like that,
that,
that Frank Sinatra music and Tony Bennett music that makes you feel successful.
Even if you're failing,
you know,
you're just walking around just buying a bunch of shit you don't even fucking
need.
Yeah.
You know,
but it all feels right because Tony Bennett's in the background,
if I ruled the world
every day would be the first day of Spring
and you'll fucking walking in and out of like lucky jeans,
you know,
what are you doing?
What are you doing?
They're building the big fucking house for the fake guy to sit in there and for
you to put your fucking kid on his lap.
Right?
Oh,
maybe the talking bunny that time a year.
Okay.
There's a big fountain and it fucking shoots off water right to the music.
You know what I mean?
There's everything other than like animals that don't get along with each other
playing,
you know,
like they always did that.
And like the fucking Disney movies,
they start rolling around each other.
Ghetto doing somersaults with leaves and butterflies and everybody was like
giggling and laughing.
Just having a great fucking time.
Like that's what nature is.
You know
it isn't,
it's like one of those fucking prison shows lockdown.
Something's getting shanked.
So he's getting killed every fucking day out there.
You have a wonder that,
why don't they ever pop?
Why not?
Why don't they ever post the murder rates out in the woods?
You know why?
Cause it'd be off the charts and there's nothing you can fucking do about it.
That's why there's no mayor in the woods,
you know?
Can't help it.
You just let the,
that you just let people sort it out.
That right there,
you look at the fucking,
not the woods.
The wilderness.
All right,
let's take it up a notch.
The woods,
that's like high school level football.
This is the,
all right,
that's how it goes.
You've got the woods wooded area,
right?
Then you have like a,
a parcel of land that's like the college level,
Division One,
and then the wilderness.
That's the fucking pros.
You know,
no society,
there's no fucking rules.
Anybody can blow anybody way.
That's how that works.
There's no trials.
No
like that shit.
All those people went through out there in Jersey and still going through with
that fucking hurricane,
that fucking New Jersey became the wilderness.
You know,
a couple of days.
Everybody's nice.
Hey,
I like your gas.
Can,
is yours empty too?
Right?
Fucking three days in four days then forget it.
But he starts getting that coyote look in their eye.
It's over fucking over.
You know,
I swear to God,
I sat here in my house watching some of that shit,
thinking,
what the fuck am I going to do when it inevitably some giant earthquake out here
in Los Angeles hits and we're just up to our fucking armpits.
What am I going to do?
You know,
I started thinking about all the people came to my door during Halloween,
you know,
and they got their little mass on and stuff.
They're all giggling and happy and that type of shit and they got their parents
kind of in the background,
you know?
You know what,
I realized those fuckers are coming back this time.
They're wearing masks for different reasons
and they ain't got
no seriously,
what the fuck am I going to do?
So I started watching that show.
You know what the,
those people who are prepping for dooms day and you're supposed to watch that
show and I guess laugh at these people on some level.
And I had to shut it off after 15 minutes and I was just like,
this guy is right.
This guy is smart.
What he's doing is smart.
It's smart to prepare for dooms day,
not even dooms day,
just do something fucked up to happen because there's too many people.
And uh,
I think it's dumb to basically just be fucking sitting here and you're your,
your whole game plan is,
um,
I'm all good.
If it's all good.
Hey,
what if chaos happens?
Well then I guess I'm fucked.
That's what I've learned.
So I'm sitting here and I'm watching these guys in that they're building these,
these things in the ground and uh,
you know,
whether you can stick food and all this type of shit or survive stuff.
And all that.
And I don't have the space for that.
I can't do it.
So all I can do is go out and I'm going to get two guns,
one for those fucking cunts coming up the walk,
and then my safety,
my backup gun,
the one when all hope is lost and I eat that last fruit loop.
I just put it to my head,
you know,
I would be ready.
There's no fee,
you know,
I'm too fucking old to learn.
Okay.
Green Baret Jujitsu,
how to grow fucking plants.
And I've just,
I'm just too fucking old.
I'm too set in my God damn waste.
All right.
I like,
you know,
I'm one of those guys,
I don't wait for the sales.
You know what I mean?
That's my mentality.
I need a coat.
I just go out and I go fucking buy one.
All right,
I'm going quick here.
I'm getting a gun and I'm shooting at,
people will come in at me and when I get down to my last bullet,
I'm a fucking idiot.
Why don't I just have one gun,
save some extra money.
Just have one gun.
You get down to the last because I'll fuck it up.
That's why click,
click,
click.
And then I had nothing left.
And then when the zombies are coming in and what am I doing?
Just start smashing myself in the head with it.
Okay.
Oh,
this podcast.
It's always so uplifting,
isn't it?
Um,
so anyways,
and what's that?
Let's do a little advertising here on the,
uh,
the Monday morning podcast would have fuckers.
Um,
all right,
here we go.
stamps.com everybody.
All right.
Some small companies think some small companies think that leasing,
leasing a postage meter is how business gets Po.
What is,
how business get postage for their letters and packages.
Oh,
businesses,
why don't I just wing this?
Because when I try and read the copy,
it makes them sound dumb.
They wrote that sentence correctly by the way.
Said some small companies that think leasing a postage meter.
Okay?
He's how businesses get postage for their letters and packages.
That isn't how they do it,
but they don't realize that there's a better way.
stamps.com everybody,
you don't want to go to the post office anymore.
stamps.com is the way to go.
Unlike a postage meter,
stamps.com has no hidden fees like meter ink charges or reset fees.
No longterm contracts,
no extra hardware to buy or lease.
stamps.com could save you up to 80% compared to a postage meter.
Plus with stamps.com you could do more than you can with the Meda.
Uh,
you can use your existing address books and tracking information to receipts
with,
with the click of a button.
The choice is clear.
stamps.com offers more features at a fraction of the cost.
I use stamps.com to set out all my DVDs when I go out on the road.
It's easy and if I can figure it out.
So can you,
so just use my last name,
Burpee,
B u r for my special offer.
Notice risk trial plus $110 bonus offer includes a digital scale and up to $55
free postage.
Um,
don't wait.
Go to stamps dot cop now stamps.com now before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of the whole page.
Type in bur bur that stamps.com and Tuber B U I,
there you go.
There you go.
Did you guys watch sports this weekend?
Oh,
are you reading about the Lord,
the Lord of all horses?
Um,
wider than an albino?
Would you get an all white horse?
First of all?
It wouldn't be all white.
It would smell like fucking shit after awhile.
It just,
it'd be like having a white coat.
You know,
you can't,
you can't lean up against anything,
you know,
p did,
he always has those all white parties.
But what they never do is they never show the,
the,
the patrons at the end of the night,
you know,
with the fucking red wine spills all over him and God knows what are,
where are the fucking heathenistic shit happens on those parties.
Um,
does he still have those that I just make a fucking reference to something from
10 years ago.
Um,
anyways,
you guys watch the watch the election.
I didn't want you any of it and I was actually terrified of the results.
You know what I mean?
I didn't like either one of those guys.
And each one of them had some shit that I was afraid if they got elected was
going to happen.
Um,
I line up with a lot of Republicans.
Shit,
surprise,
surprise.
But,
uh,
I can't,
you know,
if they would just drop that and if somebody is a,
which we should be allowed to stone them,
you know,
those guys really got a fucking,
and being gay is a choice.
Like that shit.
It's just in the world's flat and then the sun goes around the earth.
It's,
I mean,
how many votes,
how many votes would they fucking lose if they dropped those?
Jesus freaks,
psychos.
You know?
It's one of those things where sometimes it's almost like rebuilding a team
where sometimes you just got to take a step back,
which you just got to get rid of that old guy,
you know,
and move in,
move in with some new shit and just,
just wait patiently for that person to start to learn the game.
You know?
I don't fucking know.
I know because at the end of the day,
whether you elect the Democratic Guy,
the Republican guy,
those fucking consists still going to saw the tops off of the mountains.
You know they're going to still dump shit in the ocean and it there's that.
The banks are still going to do what they do.
You know,
I talked to a guy yesterday who used to work for Goldman Sachs as a waiter.
I'm like,
what do you mean as a fucking waiter?
He used to work at the top floor.
This is how bankers are limit.
He said up at the top floor,
these guys,
they had the best China,
the best silverware,
these bankers everyday for fucking lunch and they would just have these insane
meals and on the walls they had like Rembrandt's just for their own enjoyment
and this is a great thing.
That's all our money that we go down there and give to those cuts.
Begging
is,
it's the most evil fucking thing I think,
on the planet due to my limited knowledge and how some guy just told me he was a
waiter at Goldman Sachs and he seemed to have all the details.
I took everything that he had to say at a 100% face value.
MMM.
Yeah.
It's just,
it's,
you know,
I don't fucking,
something.
The amount of times I opened my mouth and by the time I realize what I'm talking
about,
I'm just so far over my head.
It's ridiculous.
Let's get back into my wheel house.
Did you guys watch any football yesterday?
He watched the football.
Hey,
how bout how bout Texas a and m beaten Alabama.
Ah,
I was a week early
Alabama.
The dream is over of the treatments tonight between meds tonight.
And you know why you're probably sitting there.
Has anybody seen this kid had Johnny Manziel?
Huh?
Johnny football is their calling him.
It's fucking guys unreal.
He's running around like Mike Vick.
Eni,
Eni can throw the ball on the run.
He can stay in the pocket.
The kits is freshmen.
I hope he doesn't get hurt the way he's running around like he does.
He's going to get killed in the NFL if he tries to do that.
But he's only a freshman and it seems like he can stand in the pocket.
Granted,
I have not watched one fucking game that he's played.
I've just watched his highlight reel,
which is the youtube video of the week.
Texas a and M Johnny Manziel.
I hope I'm saying his name right.
No disrespect.
Um,
his highlights.
You got to watch this guy and uh,
if you don't watch college football and you want to jump in some point,
this would be a great guy to watch as you watch him through his career.
Hopefully he'll play at least three years,
but if he keeps doing what he's doing,
he's probably gonna bail after his junior year.
Right.
Sophomore,
juniors and then what the kids do nowadays.
Um,
and they lost and I was too busy freaking out.
I was actually an artist actually doing,
I was trying to do some,
uh,
boyfriend girlfriend should here because I'd been on the road so much.
So on Saturday,
say they say in Boston,
come on over on Sag Friday or say um,
the hell did we do,
we went out
to this Asian cuisine place cause she's freaking out.
Cause they had these ramen noodles and not the broken wall broke,
broke ass shit.
Like the real,
the real shit,
you know,
from like behind the wall of China I believe is where they come from.
I don't fucking know.
And uh,
I go there.
I'm not a big noodle sky,
you know what I mean?
I don't like slurping that soup with all those fucking noodles.
I always,
I just,
you know,
if it's raining out,
I'm kind of a soup guy I guess.
Okay.
I just,
I just don't like it,
but she wants to go try to hear that.
Good.
All right,
let's go.
So we went there.
It was actually,
it was decent.
You know,
I got pork in mine.
You should have seen this slab of pork.
I swear to God,
if I have a heart attack instead of my life flashing before my eyes is going to
be that piece of pork gone.
That's what it was.
And then I'm going to fucking land face down.
Am I spaghettios like that fat fucking seven.
Right.
Um,
so we did that and then we went over and we saw Argo and a,
and I figured,
you know,
I figured I was done for the night,
for the day.
I figured I was done.
Yeah.
And then she mentions to me that,
uh,
you know,
somebody she know is having a,
a,
a house warming party.
Do you want to go to that?
And I was like,
no,
I don't.
I have no desire.
Why would I want to go there?
And then I just saw the look on her face and I was like,
all right,
I'll go,
I'll go at a,
I went down there.
I actually had a great time,
actually had a great fucking time,
but it's,
you know,
when you go to a house warming party though,
it just,
I dunno,
you fucking go there and you're like,
Oh wow,
they have one of those.
We should get one of those.
How do you,
how come we don't have one of those?
The ends up just costing your money.
Okay.
You know,
so I would recommend,
because the place we went,
they had a really nice house.
If you agree as a guy to go to a house warming party,
only go if you know your house is better because if you don't,
you girls get to see some shit.
Oh,
you're going to see some shit and you got to want it and next thing you know
you're going to fucking,
you're gonna,
you're gonna want to buy it,
you know?
I don't know.
Somebody already gave me shit came into my house was so like,
dude,
what are you going to like officially move into your house?
I'm like,
I am in my house.
You know,
when he kind of made a couple more fucking comments and uh,
I don't know,
I guess what you supposed to buy the house and rather than pay down the
mortgage,
you supposed to buy a bunch of shiny shit like every other fucking hands on the
block,
you know?
Yeah.
I don't have a,
I sorta have a dining room table and yet we don't have any chairs.
Shit.
All right,
I'll buy,
I'll buy the fucking chairs.
When,
when?
When I got the,
the,
the principle down to a point where I can fucking relax at night.
That's how I do it.
I get to fucking house,
I keep my air mattress or whatever the fuck I buy and I just pay the thing off
and then once I pay it off,
Dan,
you buy the chairs?
Yeah.
That all we want another TV.
Then you get the other fucking TV.
Yeah.
These fucking assholes lighten up their credit cards and paying all the fucking
interesting.
They're at the top there were at the top of the building with the finest China,
with rem breads on the wall.
And you know why that is?
You know why that is?
Okay.
I don't know.
I mean a whiteness,
I had to say,
you know why that is twice?
Because I actually don't even know why it is.
Okay,
but I'm going to try and buy as few paintings on that fucking wall is humanly
possible.
I'm going to pay these conch back.
You think I'm fucking sitting here on the hook for 30 goddamn years.
You're crazy.
All right.
And I buy,
I have to have a dining room table with no fucking chairs.
If that's the price I have to pay.
Yeah,
well they got damn.
And I'm doing it all right.
That's what I say.
And he go fuck yourself.
If you don't like it,
you know you want to come over for Thanksgiving?
Come on over.
All right.
Where's some comfy shoes?
Cause you're going to be standing up with paper plates.
All right.
And when you give me that look,
I'll fucking break out my mortgage.
Then I'll fucking put her right in your face and show you a ha ha.
What percentage io?
How I'm not it down.
How I'm giving it a fucking liver punch every month.
That's what I'm doing.
All right.
Anyway,
so I'm just fucking with you guys.
Um,
I'm not actually the angers bullshit,
but the philosophy,
the philosophy is intact.
Um,
anyways,
how about those New England patriots?
Half,
no old Gza.
Good Lord.
I swear to God,
if it wasn't,
if we didn't get 3000 yards in penalties in favor of us,
um,
I,
I'm going to say,
you know,
but you know something that bills didn't deserve the win that game anyways.
It's like they almost have like a fear of winning every time they were going to
win.
Oh my God,
we're going to score a touchdown.
Let's drop the ball on the one yard line.
Hey,
we're down by six.
If we score a touchdown here,
we'll actually win the game.
Dad Throw it to the other guy.
Okay.
I swear to God this is,
you know,
this patriots team right now is like basically what I've been watching for the
last four years where our record is way better than our team.
Like we have to score 35 to 38 points a game just for me to feel comfortable as
a fan.
And then we let up like you know,
anywhere from like 24 to 31 33 points,
but at the end of the year,
somehow we're 11 and five 12 and four and 17 point favorites in the playoffs.
And then when we lose people like that,
absolutely shocking.
It's like really,
what numbers are you looking at?
What Games are,
what games are you watching?
Yeah,
I actually think our are,
I like our front for,
and I don't mind our linebackers,
but our secondary is,
uh,
as my mom would say,
leave something to be desired.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
They make every fucking quarterback who comes in look like Joe Montana.
We don't have one lights out guy.
Like even if the rules of coverage where the were the way they were before pate
manning and the colts complained and spearheaded this movement now where if you
even,
I mean how bad with where some of those pass interference calls last week or
this past week?
I should say that first one they called on the bills.
They basically gave the Patriots and touch on the second one I guess you could
say was passing interference cause he just impeded the guy as he was trying to
cut across the end zone.
But even that one back in the day was kind of iffy.
And uh,
I dunno.
Okay.
I don't like it.
And I didn't like when we tackled their quarterback and it evidently it was our
fault that he was so short that when our linebackers stood up,
they went face mass to face mass,
you know,
and that,
that fucking Fitzpatrick,
that look of anger he had on his face,
like
throw the flag,
you know,
the whole Brady rule,
I love,
I love wow fucking dumb football fans are to where they actually blame Tom Brady
for that one.
That,
that's the NFL.
Okay.
Brady and his uggs makes the NFL a ton of fucking money and it,
and they lose a bunch of money if he's on the sideline.
Okay.
So that's basically straight across the board.
It wasn't good for the NFL last year when Peyton manning was out.
It's not good when Brady's out.
It's not what good would drew Brees,
um,
Aaron Rodgers,
any of these guys are out.
So they're completely overprotecting them.
All right.
But it took Tom Brady,
Captain America to go down for them to realize it.
That's basically what it was.
That was the straw that broke the camel's back.
And if you can't want to blame him,
Huh?
Well you go ahead and blame him,
but I know the real,
it's a money.
It's a money decision.
That's what it is.
The whole fucking thing is all about,
you know what?
What do people who are casual fans of the NFL like they like or offense,
they like scoring every fucking rule.
All right,
I'm a broken record.
You know what I'm saying?
It's just another Sunday of just like,
I literally,
at this point when I watch a game,
even if it's my team has the ball,
if I see a flag during a pass play,
I just immediately go on that fucking ball.
Shag
did.
People laughed.
They go,
you haven't even seen yet.
It's like,
I don't need to see it.
80% of them are complete horse shit.
You see what I did there?
He was covering the receiver.
You,
you can't do that.
Can't do that.
He,
he reached,
he his fingernail brushed the sleeve of the wide receiver right there.
You can't do that.
After two and a half yards,
um,
I had a fucking panic attack.
The Lakers fired their coach,
Mike Brown.
And I loved Mike Brown.
I loved everything that he was doing for the Lakers.
Okay.
I loved you guys all know.
I hate the Lakers.
I totally respect Colby Bryant.
I respect the showtime Lakers.
I actually love all those players now.
Now that they're retired and everything and I watched the highlight,
I just,
you know,
I can now just sit back
and be like,
man,
those guys,
cause they could really play the game.
And I love all the Laker fans that were there back in the day at the forum.
All right.
But this new shit,
it's a different kind of hate.
Like I'm not gonna lie.
I hated the Lakers back in the day,
but um,
I hated the team and it was the same,
basically the same team every year after year.
For the most part.
That core group of guys was the same group of guys,
but this,
this fucking shit.
Now,
you know,
with everybody just piling on like Dwight Howard,
Dwight Howard blew up that team out there in Orlando.
The guy was a fucking cancer.
He drove his fucking coach out of town.
They faced the Lakers in the finals.
He's posting up against like fucking,
uh,
Pau Gasol.
Oh,
was it buying them?
I don't fucking know.
But you know,
all of those guys should have been in foul trouble with how big the a body he
was.
And he didn't do shit.
You didn't do shit.
So now what does he do?
He joins the fucking Lakers.
He's dancing with Ellen and everybody's acting like this guys,
this fucking savior.
Right?
So they come in there,
they're not winning shit.
Blame it on Mike Brown.
He gets fucking bounced out.
What she should have,
they should have fired him after last year.
They should have fired him that time when Colby walked back to the bench and
went to high five them and Colby completely blew him off right there.
He's lost the team.
But you never know with Colby.
You know what I mean?
You know that guy.
He's always fucking,
but I respect what he does.
He just wants to fucking win.
If you suck,
he doesn't try and hide it.
He will embarrass you on TV.
And I guess he's a,
he's earned the fucking right to do that.
Okay.
I'd be pretty even handed here for a Celtics Fan.
You've got,
you've got to give me that.
All right.
A person with though it Laker flag flapping in the wind as you drive down the
street.
Um,
so anyways,
they fire Mike Brown and then I hear that they're talking to fucking Phil
Jackson and I,
I can't even tell you how fucking depressed I was when I heard that Phil
Jackson,
Jackson Jackson would possibly be coming back to the Lakers.
I,
it was,
it was the same hopeless feeling I have when I watch baseball where it's the
fact that there's no salary cap in baseball,
like hoping that the Yankees are going to suck.
It's just never going to happen again.
They got too much fucking money.
Although the red sox have demonstrated that you can spend 180 million and still
suck.
Yeah.
Um,
and come in last place,
which I believe we did,
but,
and I know what you're thinking.
You're like,
well,
the fucking NBA has,
has a salary cap.
They don't have a hard cap.
They have a salary cap.
This is the salary cap.
But you can go beyond it and if you have enough fucking money you can fucking,
uh,
you know,
you can grease some palms and will allow you to put together these Juggernaut
fucking horseshit bullshit championship
teams.
Or I should say a new breed of championship teams.
All right.
Like I don't think
a lot of these championship teams like I,
it just kills me that these guys
just pile on now and then you get your ring,
which is fine,
cause I guess that's the way it's done nowadays.
But the fact that you then put on ESPN and they start bringing up guys like Bill
Russell,
Larry Bird,
magic Johnson,
you know,
all these fucking greats who stuck with their team,
and a lot of them didn't get their fucking rings.
You,
you,
you earned a ring back in the day.
That's all I'm saying.
This shit now with this is like the timeout generation type shit.
You know,
where everybody gets a fucking ribbon.
So I'm sitting there thinking like,
oh my God,
they're going to get Phil Jackson.
I was like,
oh my God,
they're going to get,
they're going to get Phil Jackson and Dwight Howard who blew up a fucking team,
choked in the finals,
got his coach fucking fired,
is now going to get a ring and those fucking console ESPN ago lathers up plan
how they're going to end the lineage of great Laker centers.
Kareem,
they would actually mentioned them in the same breath is Kareem and shack,
you know,
we'll fucking chaebol and edge just,
it drives me nuts.
Do you realize the Lakers have never had a fucking great center that was there?
Do you understand that,
that they have been buying centers around the league,
like Paris Hilton getting shoes their entire fucking lives.
None of that great centers where they guys will Chamberlain,
you know,
he played on like every fucking team.
Evidently he was a piece of work.
Um,
I think he did was he fucked every chicken,
the city when he was done,
he switched teams.
So,
um,
Kareem they got from the box shack they got from Orlando.
And obviously Dwight Howard,
they get from fucking Orlando and it's just,
it's like watching a fucking rich kid,
you know,
whatever.
You know,
I just cracked up my corvette,
you know,
you're like,
oh good,
now he's got to take the bus and no daddy and mommy buy him a new one.
He drives,
you know,
drives to school with it the next fucking day.
So I'm psyched that Phil Jackson didn't come back.
It just kills me that like that,
that that franchise is so fucking insane that they have Phil Jackson on speed
dial to come in whenever they have a fucking problem.
Like Harvey Keitel in pulp fiction.
He's like the cleaner,
like he's just going to come in.
Oh my God,
we lost four games in a row.
Call Up Phil Jackson.
It's like,
well I'm sitting there going,
well what the fuck don't the Celtics caught while we got,
you know,
we have a coach,
but I'm just saying,
I don't fucking know.
I am happy that Celtics got a little bit younger,
but um,
this is going to kill me when the Lakers pass the Celtics and
championships cause they're going to do it because,
uh,
the people just want to,
why wouldn't you want to play out here?
Beautiful weather.
Fuck celebrities dance with Ellen.
Yeah.
Know
how the fuck are the Celtics going to compete with that?
That's cold eight months of the year and then it gets unbearably hot.
No celebrities.
Sandag
we've got good lobster,
lobster.
Um,
I dunno.
I don't fucking know.
And I swear to God if one more fucking Laker fan brings up the fucking,
you know,
Celtics Championship with the big three and it's like,
well you guys to,
I realize we did it and I've said it a zillion times.
We bought a championship that year.
All right.
It didn't feel the same as when we went in the fucking eighties.
But you guys are doing this shit year in and fucking year out.
It just,
just racking up these fucking championships going around the league,
picking up free agents like you're some fat fuck at a salad bar.
You know,
it just kills me.
It fucking kills me that this is how you're going to do it.
What can we do in Boston to compete with fucking la?
You know what I would do?
This is what it,
who's kidding,
who the,
the basket basketball is like what?
Like 90% African American.
All right.
So right there you have to somehow make Boston a city that an African American
is going,
going to want to live in.
All right.
And uh,
if you want an like,
we don't,
we don't get good ratings with that crowd.
I'm going to go out on a limb and say a lot of people,
a lot of people,
African Americans do not have any interest to go to Boston to check out the
freedom trail or Paul Revere's house considering the stories that they've heard
about that city.
You know,
it's funny that Boston gets such a bad reputation for being racist where you
know,
like as opposed to what La with their great racial harmony that they have out
here.
Every time the Lakers win a championship,
it's like they're happy for five minutes before they start trying to like kill
police officers,
Tipping Open fucking cruises and all that type of shit.
You know,
the last unbelievable race riot in this fucking country was here,
the filthiness of the LAPD and all that fucking bullshit.
Okay.
You know,
allegedly killed Biggie had fucking gang members in the amount of fucking them.
But for some reason,
I know the fucking reason,
but I'm just saying we,
that's still hanging around our fucking neck.
Like an Albatross.
The average black person,
if you say Boston,
what's the first thing you know about it?
They say it's,
it's,
it's a racist city.
That's basically what the here,
so that's what the fuck we're working on in this new era of going out and buying
championships.
You notice Lebron didn't even swing by where the fuck we were at,
you know?
Um,
so this is what I would do
as far as the black people.
I know,
you know,
if you start talking conspiracy conspiracy theory there,
they're on board.
Not all of them,
but a lot of them.
So what I would do is I would basically,
I would make the Zike guide of Los Angeles.
I would show them that film and then,
and then take them on the freedom trail.
I would just show la falling into the ocean after some epic fucking,
uh,
you know,
that big earthquake that's supposed to come,
and then the footage that I would use to show like how it's on fire and all that
type of shit would be the Rodney king riots.
And um,
and then to ease all this type of shit,
I would be playing that song that I love La.
I love La.
And then you cut to Rodney king getting the shit kicked out of him.
You know,
what I made and all their awful cops.
And I would just show every fucking bad shit about them.
And then I'd have a scientist come in,
talk about how many people are out there versus how much actual water is being
piped into this fucking city.
I'd show video footage of how the Colorado River does not reach the ocean
anymore.
And uh,
yeah,
that's what I would do.
I would make a Hollywood movie to trash Hollywood and then I,
and then I would just show them like lake Winnipesaukee up in,
uh,
up in New Hampshire.
I would just,
let's just say,
listen,
the doll is about ready to crash.
We've taken on too much debt.
You know,
you want to be where the trees are,
where the fresh water is.
We'll build you your own fallout shelter with a full court,
full NBA court,
uh,
inside of it.
Whatever your favorite junk food is.
A,
we'll fucking have like 20 refrigerators looking like MTV cribs,
you know,
you be able to ride out any storm and then he'd come out and we start the league
again with 80% less people living in this country after the fallout.
Right.
Does that sound like a plan?
Anybody from the Celtics Organization is listening.
I am available.
Um,
all right,
let's get to the,
uh,
the,
this is going to be a long podcast this week cause I'm already 47 minutes in and
I'm just getting to the,
uh,
the stories and the questions here.
All right,
uh,
alcohol hiccups.
Last week I mentioned that I had,
uh,
almost terminal hiccups after the Lsu game and just basically I'm,
I didn't get gout
the way I,
what I did to my body last weekend.
Um,
anyways,
so this guy says here,
hey bill,
sorry to hear about the hiccups at the Lsu game.
Those special ones that don't go away or the worst.
I've suffered from bad acid reflux since I was in college and I'm 35 now.
So I've tried about every remedy out there and I've learned a lot about it.
Uh,
the hiccups you get when you're drunk and had been eating all day,
our extra horrible because they do not go away no matter what you do.
I've had nights,
I've had nights out ruined by this.
Yeah,
you can't hit on some chicken if you got the fucking hiccups.
Um,
you said I had night's ruined by this until I finally figured it out.
I doubt you'll see this advice on any website.
Most people who never experienced this will tell you to take something for it or
do something that would cure regular everyday hiccups.
It won't work.
The last thing you need to do to his stomach that's full and that screwed up his
add something else to it.
Yeah,
cause that's what I was doing.
I was trying to hold my nose and drink water.
Um,
he says if you ever get hiccups like that,
if it happens again,
find an out of the way,
place,
uh,
or an or not take your finger and gently touch your tonsils until you puke.
You need to get that evil out of you.
It's the only way.
As long as you don't drink too much more after that,
I'm supposed to keep drinking after that.
It's supposed to run behind a dumpster,
like a fucking bulimic and then keep drinking.
All right,
I'm going to be open minded here.
I,
he goes,
your hiccups will be gone and you can go on with your night shouting at college
kids or whatever you feel like doing.
Um,
all right.
I'm sure that that does work because I guess you're getting all the fucking shit
out of your stomach that,
I mean,
I don't,
I don't want to,
but the fact that you would then you're like,
get that evil out of your stomach so then you can put more evil into it.
That's like getting out of a bad relationship and then going out and dating
another psycho,
you know?
Do you know when I actually,
when I got rid of the hiccups is what I did was I came home and I just started
eating right and I stopped putting evil in my stomach and I was fine.
But um,
I would,
I would probably say what you want to do is yet stop eating and then the next
time you get hungry,
I would have like a salad,
maybe some lemon water,
something really easy on the stomach.
And I would think that they would go away naturally.
But I guess if you're in a pinch,
I don't want to ever,
I don't want to ever like promote going up and puking and then you're basically
like a,
you're like a partying bulimic were bulimic.
We'll go out and eat like fudge and cake and all that shit.
They're not supposed to have an a pizza and then go out and puke it up.
You're doing that I guess with like alcohol in potato skins.
MMM.
Interesting theory.
I'm sure it works,
but I,
I'm not willing to pay the price,
but thank you for,
uh,
for trying to help.
I'm just,
I'm just gonna try not to swam five Michelob and then eat like fucking a sausage
king of Burger and in some sort of po boy sandwich all within like two hours.
I think I had some scotch in there too.
I can't even remember.
Oh,
Jamison.
Anyways,
here we got bill from the military.
Um,
I have faithfully served in the military for five years now.
I currently have three years left to go on my illest enlistment.
Jesus.
Dude,
don't you re up after four.
So I guess that's what you did.
There's no eight year enlistment.
Is there?
Yeah.
Do you start as a Sajan?
Um,
let me pre face my dilemma by saying that I loved the military.
It has provided me with opportunities I wouldn't have never dreamed of.
It got me out of the dead end life that I was living in my podunk,
Texas town.
I've been to places and experiences,
experienced things that I never would have thought possible before.
I made so many great friends and bonds that will land at last a lifetime.
Now,
within the past couple four years,
I've come to the realization that we in the military are just pawns for these
corporate scum Fox to make a buck.
We go to war for money and resource control.
People think that we're fighting for freedom or anybody.
People that think worth fighting for freedom or anybody else's freedom either
has their head up their ass or they are just uninformed.
I'm sure you know this,
all of this already,
so we'll save you the rent.
There are ways I can get out of my enlistment early and maintain an honorable
stay status.
Now with the war drums beating for Iran like they did for Iraq almost a decade
ago.
Do I try and get out early and risks feeling like a coward and a pussy for the
rest of my life or do I stay in and risk dying or watching friends dies for a
cause?
I no longer believe in sincerely anonymous military member.
MMM.
Yeah.
I all,
well the first thing I would say is when,
uh,
when you're presenting your opinions.
Okay.
All of it's great,
but if you say people who don't get it,
uh,
you should just say don't have access to the information they need when you go
have their head up their ass.
Anybody who's just listening to this is now immediately like pulling back.
Yeah.
Look,
uh,
I can't argue with any of that.
Okay.
Yeah.
No,
I don't think you're a coward if you don't re up.
You already fought in a war,
you know what I mean?
You don't believe in it.
Yeah,
I would,
I would definitely get out.
I mean,
as far as this last thing,
I was all about go get a Sama bin.
Ladin okay.
I'm believing what you're telling me that he was behind those attacks.
We need to go in there and go get that fucking guy.
But I never for once believed that we were going to Iraq to try and liberate
those people.
You know,
I mean,
shit,
the corporations and government,
they don't give a fuck about people who live here.
Why would they give a shit about people over there?
They don't give a fuck.
Could give a flying fuck.
Okay,
I totally agree with that.
All right.
So,
and I was saying was our guy,
and we didn't give a shit what he was doing as long as he was doing what we want
them to do.
And then when he didn't and he started going rogue,
you know,
we,
uh,
all of a sudden we're like,
hey,
this bad guy that we're in business with is a bad guy.
He's evil.
For some reason,
we didn't notice that for the first 15 fucking years we were in business with
them.
Wherever the fuck it was first 10 years,
what do we put him in?
I always get confused.
Was it like in the seventies or something?
Yeah.
Like he gassed his people and we didn't get outraged.
You know enough to do something for like another fucking eight years.
I mean,
I,
you know,
I don't,
I don't fucking know.
I,
my experience that I've learned from traveling is that,
that people are people,
you know,
we're just a,
the average person is not evil.
You know,
they're walking around that they want,
they want a job,
they want to be able to provide for their family and they want to find true
love.
That's all they really want.
They don't want to control other people and all that.
It's just,
it's,
I dunno,
what would you say 15%
of of the population is a sociopath's?
Is it higher than that?
Those are the people.
I don't know.
I,
it's,
it's just too depressing to talk topic to discuss.
I would get out,
okay,
you're lucky enough to survive.
You did your duty.
If you don't believe in it in any more,
you know,
and who can fucking question you.
They keep him,
questioned me and say that I'm full of Shit.
I'm some fucking jackass who never went.
You don't sit in here.
You could definitely trash me.
But you,
if you're there and that's what you're seeing and that's what your gut is
telling you,
you gotta act on it.
That's what I was saying.
All right.
That's what they did say.
Um,
yeah.
That shit's just too fucking depressing.
I hate seeing that.
I hate,
like,
I hate listening to rhetoric that's trying to make me afraid of other fucking
people.
They're going to do this.
They are going to do that.
They're going to do that.
That's exactly what the fuck they saying over there.
They ain't going to do this.
They ain't going to do that.
They did this,
they did that and then everybody gets all fucking amped up.
You know?
And then this is,
this is completely unoriginal
thought.
Everybody knows us.
And then the cons,
who gets everybody all stirred up.
They don't fucking do shit.
They sit back and watch everybody,
they got all stirred up and then they hope that their team fucking wins.
Um,
yeah,
so I would get out,
I will get out.
I mean,
I,
yeah,
it takes balls to get out to say fuck this.
Don't give into that.
Peer pressure.
You're,
you're,
you already did it.
You already did it.
All right.
I'm just keep saying the same thing over and over again,
so yeah.
Okay.
Yeah.
All right.
Animal Control Officer.
Mr. Byrd,
I'm a big fan and I caught your show in Cincinnati,
uh,
in October.
You killed it.
Thanks for the laughs.
I'm an animal control officer and Kentucky and I have been and have been for two
years.
The job is really getting me down.
Lately I have to euthanize animals.
This used to not be a problem for me because I felt it was a necessary evil.
Jesus Christ,
he's going to be most depressing fucking emails ever.
Ah,
here we go.
I deal with some of the lowest people on the planet and I'm starting to hate
people.
I would rather put down the low life owners then the poor fucking animals that
didn't get a fair shot.
Okay.
Wow.
Somebody who you know that's fucking crush should be in a movie.
Somebody just snap it in an animal shelter.
Yeah.
Hey,
whoa.
Hold it down.
Hold down spot.
You know,
and you'd get them to hold them down and then you fucking stick it in their
neck.
They have that,
you know,
like great confused.
Look somebody has,
when they realize that they're being killed in the tables turned and movies.
It's one of my favorite scenes in those movies.
But wait,
I meet you.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
I come home mentally drained in the animal control community.
They call it compassion fatigue.
Yeah.
God.
In another life,
I really want to go the corporate route cause I just want to be in a room when
they're pitching.
Like what,
what can we call this?
MMM.
Doggy dts,
Nah,
that dts,
that's too much like a addiction.
Then somebody comes up with compassion fatigue and they actually get a fucking
high five
and they all go out and get a taco salad ever fucking idiots.
Um,
plus I worked for a micro managing cont.
The pays pretty good for my area of the world and I have really good benefits.
My problem is I got offered a shit job making less money with less benefits.
The job would required me to travel more,
which is great for me.
I just have a problem walking away from the cash and the benefits.
I have a son,
so I want to provide as best as possible for him,
but I feel like I should take my happiness into consideration.
Also helped me out here a walk and be happier or stay and make more money.
Thanks for the podcast.
Go Fuck Yourself.
A PSD.
You get tired of people telling you to go fuck yourself.
Um,
uh,
no,
not really.
Now that you just said that,
I guess it's getting a little old.
MMM.
Anyways,
but then again,
I say it at the end of my every fucking one.
Where am I?
What the fuck are we talking about?
Um,
well,
I,
I would walk and choose happiness.
You'll be a happier dead all the kid really fucking wants.
He wants to know that he's safe and that he's loved.
All right.
And you know,
there's a bunch of kids out there who have iPads and all that fucking crap and
their dad's never around.
I swear to God,
you know what the greatest thing when I was a kid was when my dad had time to go
out in the backyard and throw the fucking ball around.
If you just do that,
I don't give a shit where you live in,
you know?
And we had up to the up and down financial times when I was growing up,
we had a house,
we lost the house,
moved into a duplex.
You,
but I still had a great time.
You know,
I still had a fucking great time.
So kids [inaudible] your kid isn't going to know that you're making less money
unless you're making like fucking 700 grand a year to,
uh,
put dogs down and then you go to making 30 grand a year.
But,
um,
you're,
you're fine.
You're fine.
I would think
I would choose happiness.
All right.
So there you go.
Once again.
Now the question in way over my head,
I was never in the military.
I don't have a son.
Yeah.
You know,
so take that with a grain of salt.
Anyways,
wife's weird sex store purchase.
Oh,
G,
here we go.
Wife's weird.
Um,
dear bill,
me and my wife had been married for two months and she has been less involved
and willing to have sex.
All right.
Right there.
And she got up a weird sex store purchase.
I don't even need to read the rest of this,
sir.
Have it a knelt.
Um,
anyways,
he goes,
I thought the honeymoon phase was just ending and started to adapt.
It's been two weeks since we last had sex and Friday while taking out the
garbage,
I found a bag to the local sex shop.
Okay.
That's it.
I don't need to read anymore.
Just get it a nulled go your separate way.
I didn't know what she bought and since we haven't been having sex,
it was a puzzler.
Okay.
That's it to,
it's this whole fucking thing.
It's over.
I then started snooping.
Okay.
That's it.
While she was at work and found a Dildo in the closet.
I know women have them,
but this one wasn't your usual dildo up.
Okay.
Nothing to see here.
Yeah.
Dude,
this has more red flags than the,
than the fucking opening ceremony of China at the Olympics.
Okay.
Was it your usual Dildo?
Jumping back in.
We're losing a lot of tiles.
I think we're going to burn up here and fucking reentry.
Um,
it was the shape of an animal's penis
there lady.
Keep everything.
I'm just going to take my t shirts and my shoes and a pair of pants.
It was close to a foot long.
Yeah,
and weirdly shaped.
Wait a minute.
They don't make animal dildos to what?
What does an animal penis even look like?
I don't even,
I've seen an elephant.
Fuck.
It was the scariest thing I've ever seen in my life.
Seen Dogs.
Bang.
Anyways,
it was close to a foot long and weirdly shaped.
I have kept quiet,
but I really want to confront her but don't know how to do it without hurting
her feelings or opening a crazy can of worms.
Please help bill.
All right dude.
You know
you,
you need,
if you're not just going to walk,
you really need professional help on this one.
All right.
I mean,
ha ha.
I don't know what,
what do you do?
Do you take the thing out of the trash and then just leave it on the fucking
coffee table and then she walks in and just,
you're just pacing.
Hey honey,
how was your day?
And you just fucking wait.
What?
What's this?
I just found this in the fucking trash,
Huh?
Which orifice will you shoving this in?
I mean,
there's no fucking way to,
how do you even bring that up?
Listen,
do I got to tell you this right now?
Your wife has a huge dildo now.
Your wife has,
or your wife has a huge skeleton.
Subdued.
Did something gigantic going on.
I've got a kid,
got to stop seeing gigantic and huge.
She's got a big secret.
Bigger than that fucking Giraffe Dildo you found in the fucking garbage.
Um,
you're,
you're two months in dude,
and you're already not getting the sex is already a fucking issue.
All right.
Now it sounds like you really loved this woman.
The fact that you're actually still willing to work this out,
but as an outsider with no feelings,
no,
no heart,
no broken heart on the line here.
Um,
you know,
I,
I think he just got a walk.
I see.
I know.
You know what I,
what would I say?
I would just say,
I'm literally sitting here right now guys,
and I'm,
I'm,
I'm rubbing my eyes.
You know,
when you do that with one hand,
you know that move,
I'm doing that right now.
Trying to think of how to fucking,
how do I bring this up?
Okay.
I would take the fucking hippo cock
and I would,
I would put it in one of those big brown bags,
if it can fit from Macy's,
whatever you got to do.
Maybe like one of those,
you know,
when they plastic wrap,
like a Christmas tree,
I would find one of those bags and I'd stick it in that
and I would just say,
honey,
I need to talk to you about something.
All right.
And I would sit it down,
dude.
Fuck this and fuck a fucking feelings.
All right,
I see.
I had to get past the shock here.
All right.
Just sit her down and say,
listen,
I'm not judging you.
Um,
I,
you know,
I just need some honesty here because
this is a gigantic,
huge
fucking gorilla dick that I found.
It's trash.
Okay?
You haven't been having sex with me.
It's going on.
What is,
just tell me what is going on.
I'm not going to tell anybody about this other than this podcast.
I'm not going to judge you just level with me.
Do you?
Is this why you wanted to go to the zoo the other day?
No,
just you got to get it out there,
dude.
You got to get it out there and you have to hear her fucking story and you have
to be supportive both for her feelings and for you,
for the fact that you deserve to know the fucking truth about this before you
spend the rest of your life with somebody who's going to bang you once every two
months while secretly wanting to fuck a tiger.
Well,
what I,
I'll,
I'll fucking grizzly bear do this.
No,
they don't make animal dildos and I swear to God,
you fucking assholes.
If there is a website,
don't send me the link because I'm not looking at it.
I don't need that on my hard drive.
I'm not looking at it,
dude.
You have to sit her down.
Okay.
And,
and you,
you have to bring,
you got to bring in that Zebra Dick.
You just have to do it.
You got to do it.
You gotta do it.
You all would see yourself.
All right.
And as much as it's going to be embarrassing for her and everything,
it's going to help her out because I bet that there's a part of her that she,
she doesn't like herself,
that she's sneaking around and starting to live this lie and all our are or
whatever the fuck is going on.
I Dunno.
I would also bring it,
maybe bring it to the sex store and ask somebody what this is before.
Like you make a complete ass of yourself.
Cause God knows what.
If it's something else,
what if it's like a fucking,
uh,
you know,
you don't let those wood things that's on an old staircase.
Um,
I don't fucking know.
Uh,
all right.
On a banister.
Um,
all right.
Hey,
here's a classic we're bringing back that I had to drop because I think a Daniel
tosh already did.
Uh,
is it racist thing?
But this falls under the category of is it racist,
racist,
racist.
Um,
all right.
Is this guy okay?
Man,
this shit has been bothering me for about a week and I can't let it go.
I work at a national laboratory with a lot of employees,
a lot,
a l,
a,
l,
O,
t,
a lot of employees,
everyone in between,
ranging from the Dorky phd scientists with no skills to the janitor and
groundskeeper.
Two words.
Who's usually
are either immigrants or just g,
e,
D I n educated people.
Okay.
Anyways,
I'm a pretty social guy who walks,
who talks to everyone and gets along with most.
Uh,
I'd been working here for eight years and know a lot of people.
A L,
l,
O,
t of people here.
It's a l.
O.
T.
Um,
well there is this janitor dude named Montez.
If the name Devon,
give it away.
He is black and I myself are,
are pretty white.
Okay?
Montez doesn't strike me as a black guy's name.
And your grammar is terrible.
Uh,
not shockingly Caucasian as yourself,
but pretty close.
Well,
I thought I was kind of friends with Montez as I would frequently bullshit with
him at work throughout the years.
I've been working here until just last week.
All right,
so basically you're a scientist with this fucking bad grammar.
Um,
anyways,
this is smoking hot young girl who that was hired about a year ago,
a 21 year old delicious Lee Young Black Girl Name Patricia.
All right.
Delicious.
Lee made it creepy.
Um,
at my work
it,
my work of scientists,
there are a lot of good looking women in the building,
so any good looking chick gets noticed.
So she was going to school to be a nurse and for whatever personal reasons she
quit school.
She works as a janitor.
Oh.
So she works as a janitor there.
The delicious Lee young black girl.
Um,
so last week on bullshitting with Montez and I'm asking him where his partner is
referring to,
Patricia,
he asked me who I respond,
the young girl who was going to school to be a nurse.
And he goes,
and I don't know what possessed me,
but I added in the conversation that girl,
that girl shouldn't have quit school.
It's stupid to just quit as it only takes a few years to rough that shit out.
And then you have a degree and nobody can take it from you.
Uh,
this is when Monte has got pissed off.
He says to me,
don't call my friends stupid.
He says,
I'm like,
what?
Uh,
shut the fuck up man.
She should.
Oh,
you're like,
I'm like,
what?
Shut the fuck up man.
She should have finished school.
Don't you agree?
Otherwise she stuck here being a janitor with no education.
And you said this to a janitor.
Ah,
that's a good move.
Uh,
but if she graduates,
she can move anywhere and still have that,
that piece of paper,
blah,
blah.
And he spells piece p a,
I.
C.
E.
Um,
and this guy is bitching about this other guy.
Okay.
He replies,
not if she don't want to be a nurse.
What if she wants to be a January janitor?
I fall.
I followed with,
that's fucked up.
And if it was your own daughter when you want her to finish school now he's all
sorts of pissed off.
He makes comments about how you'll be happy on Wednesday,
won't you?
Referring to the election.
I think he was taking a shot at me and I wanted Rodney and office.
I realized he had just pulled the race card and I can't believe it after
insulting him and what he does for a living,
um,
egos.
I asked him,
are you fucking serious?
He gets all thug and tries staring at me with this hate acting all hard.
Like he wants to fight me.
We're both 40 plus years old.
All the while there are people near us who are starting,
who hear us starting to argue fighting is not acceptable at work.
Not even arguing,
especially about a race issue.
It's not politically correct and all that bullshit.
Um,
if this were a high school,
we would have been fighting,
but I'm 42 years old and have a mortgage and a career,
et cetera.
This dude is also about five foot 10,
one 80,
and I'm a lot bigger than him.
So what do I do?
I apologize to him,
dude.
If I said something to Piss you off,
I didn't mean it.
And I apologize.
He continues being a dick to where I tell him I apologize once motherfucker and
that shit is not going to happen again.
And now I'm getting pissed off and people starting to stare and I have to walk
away.
But before I do,
I tell him under my breath that he's his stupid motherfucker and go clean some
shit.
Okay.
Jesus Christ dude.
Then he goes,
what did I do wrong there
other than the parting shot I gave him?
I can't stop thinking about it.
I mean,
I liked the guy and that's what pisses me off about it most.
Am I fucking racist or is it him?
Uh,
I don't think I said anything out of out of line,
but maybe I did before telling him to fuck off that is I'm going to see this
mother fucker at work and I have a hard time with letting things go,
but my job is more important.
Just wanted your advice.
Is it me?
Yeah.
Dude.
Actually,
I don't know if you're racist,
but you're,
you're,
you're an idiot.
You're an idiot.
You walked up to a janitor
and you basically,
you belittled what he did for a living before you even said,
why don't you go clean some shit?
All right.
And you also didn't take into consideration that it could have been like,
uh,
financial reasons why she quit.
You know,
who knows?
Who knows why she fucking quit?
It doesn't make sense that someone would quit nursing to then go up and,
and,
and be a janitor.
So right there,
you should have fucking left it alone.
That usually means some sort of fucking drama happened.
Who the fuck knows what happened?
Something happened.
There could be a zillion fucking scenarios
as to why she became w ended up being,
uh,
working there as a janitor.
All right.
And you're saying to a janitor who at this point is in his forties,
he's still a fucking janitor.
He's taken pride in what the he's doing.
You know,
people shit on Janet is all the fucking time.
He knows that anybody who goes around cleaning up shit,
they know what people are going to be saying.
Do you know you're supposed to treat everybody with fucking respecting it did.
So look what you're saying is right,
but you said it to the wrong guy.
You know,
if you had a daughter,
you wouldn't want to quit nursing school then become a janitor.
He wouldn't,
but you don't fucking say that to a janitor.
You know?
And you're also kind of a creep where you sitting there saying,
she's a delicious Lee young black girl.
I'm going to say that this some more shit going on with you.
And uh,
why will you act asking why,
where this delicious you,
first of all,
you fucking 42 fucking years old.
You shouldn't be looking at some 21 year old girl,
like she's delicious.
You fucking creep.
Sorry this took me a minute,
dude,
you're fucking creep and you're a moron and you're allegedly as scientists and
you can't even spell.
So I don't even,
I don't know what you do over there.
This is bad right now.
Cause now I'm insulting you and you're not gonna learn anything from the shit.
Like,
dude,
all right,
here's some rules.
And then you never make fun of what somebody does for living.
All right.
And I'm not going to judge you because I did that one time.
I got into a fight with somebody and he was a bartender and um,
I was working in a club and the guy was in the middle of washing glasses and I,
we've gotten this fucking argument about sports,
red sox,
Yankees,
Shit.
And I said,
I'll go wash a fucking glass.
Not realizing
that I,
I didn't mean it like I was belittling what the fuck he did.
He,
he was just washing glasses.
So I said it and I did and he fucking like was ready to stab me.
And I actually,
someone told me later,
dude,
you can't fucking say that shit.
And I was like,
I didn't mean it that way.
Fuck came about by,
once I got on my ego,
I learned.
I was like,
all right,
I can't do that.
And you,
you can't sit there at your level.
You're at an a and an economic level above this fucking guy.
Although I,
the way you spelled,
you know,
I don't know,
you can't do that dude.
You,
you,
I dunno if you're going to get it,
but like to say that shit in the end to call,
say that he's dumb
and then say go,
go fucking clean.
Something like,
but
I dunno,
that's one of those things where it just escalated and then he got your grill
and he's fucking act like he's going to kick the shit out of you.
And then you got mad.
So then you said that shit.
And then he gets the think,
you see that you were thinking that shit the whole fucking time,
which you probably weren't right until then.
You know.
So what you basically did is you ruined the next 60 white people that black dude
is going to run into because he's going to keep thinking about you.
So,
um,
this is the deal.
That's some shit you can't apologize for.
Like,
you guys are never going to be friends again.
Um,
but you still should apologize.
I Dunno.
And then what's he gonna do?
Act like he's going to kick the shit out of you and then it's going to fuck.
I am,
I think it might be a wrap.
Just might be a fucking rap.
I don't know.
I felt halfway through that I was trashing them for being a fucking janitor.
You know?
What did we learn that people don't make fun of?
Janner don't make fun of somebody being a janitor to a janitor because they're
going to get mad.
Uh,
I don't know about you,
dude.
You're a creep.
Look,
I'm not gonna sit there and actually is a 44 year old guy.
You know,
it's,
I don't see a girl in her twenties and if she's fucking gorgeous,
you know,
but I always address that.
I'm 44 years old.
I always address it like if I'm with somebody,
but I'm with somebody,
like we make a joke about how fucking old we are or something like that.
But the older I get,
the more I start thinking like,
why would you dress like that?
Don't you realize the fucking asshole you're going to be attracting to you?
You know,
there's something about that word delicious,
Lee.
It's just absolutely fucking disgusting.
And I feel,
I think you're a creep.
Okay.
You know,
sub level,
you're that fucking guy that ruins it.
You know,
you're the one that takes it into that creepy fucking area than the,
and it's just such a creep that you make the person you're with feel like a
fucking pervert,
you know?
Uh,
I don't know who the fuck knows.
All right,
that's the podcast for this week.
Um,
I am in Connecticut old building.
I wanted to hint,
hint,
hint.
Um,
wait a second.
What a fuck is my website?
My website,
by the way?
Bill bird.com if you'd like to go to that.
Oh.
And if you want to,
you know,
help support the troops,
amazon.com all you do is go to my podcast page.
If you click on the podcast page,
you'll see a link to go to amazon.com and if you buy something,
they gave me a,
they gave me,
they kicked me back a little bit of money,
and then I take that money and I'd take a little bit of that and I give it to
the wounded warriors project.
All right.
That's what I do.
That's what I do here on the podcast.
So anyways,
shows,
this is where I'm going to be.
I'm going to be at southern Connecticut University and a that's open to both
students and the public.
So if you live in Connecticut and you'd like to go to southern Connecticut
University,
watch me do my shit.
I'd appreciate it.
And uh,
that's November 17th,
which is what's today,
the 12th that's five days away.
Tuesday,
Wednesday,
Thursday,
Friday.
So that's a Saturday.
And then I'll be at the Brayer Improv in Bray,
California November 30th,
December 1st and second.
That is the deal.
Oh yeah,
that's it.
That's the podcast.
Go fuck yourselves.
Have a great week.